[Music]
the thing about war is it only works if
both sides to leave they're the good
guys the truth is we're not so different
we fight to get back what was once ours
[Music]
but in the end and this is the end it's
just a city you'll get used to watching
them fall like we're safe for now we
need to figure out our next vote felt
there's no next move and there is no we
what is that we're not here to eat those
pork none on the shrimp oh this guy's
got pork god you're weird
I'm not looking for Super Friends that
doesn't matter can't fight these people
not even with whatever it is your hand
can do it's cheap it's not they're
hunting our friends our family and I'm
not gonna stop there
[Music]
more gasses coming
and the only thing keeping Manhattan for
crumble into a pile of dust as the four
of you the war for New York it's over
not yet
[Music]
eyes ears horns
I can see you've formed a kind of pond
I promise he was temporary
[Music]
electronic they will disappoint you
Jessica like it or not
you go out there together
that we found each other I'm not hugging
you it's been a long week
[Music]